bonjour et bienvenue pour cette non mes
erreurs corrigées moins ça tout de suite
non nous n'allons pas vous parler que de
requins mais de poissons cartilagineux
alors oui dit comme ça poissons
cartilagineux et requins ça un peu l'air
d'être la même chose
alors voilà la différence poissons
cartilagineux requins par qu'un poisson
cartilagineux requins par le cas oui
c'est étonnant dit comme ça non pas vous
expliquer le pourquoi du comment
et ce n'est pas parce que les plus
grands se font avoir et confondre les
deux qu'il faut faire pareil
commençons tout d'abord par une mise au
point qu est ce qu un poisson
cartilagineux primo dans poissons
cartilagineux il y à poisson est un
poisson c'est un être vivant possédant
une colonne vertébrale et des branchies
donc ça c'est un poisson ça c'est un
poisson et ça buzz est un poisson aussi
à mais on vous a peut-être dit que les
dauphins n'étaient pas des poissons mais
des mammifères pourtant regardez les
mammifères ont une colonne vertébrale et
un moment du développement de l'embryon
ils ont même des branchies ses branchies
se transforme ensuite en divers éléments
de votre crâne et forme votre mâchoire
votre oreille interne ou bien encore
votre culotte dans la vie de tous les
jours le mot poisson à une définition
qui s'applique très bien en partie de
pêche
mais pas du tout aux fossiles ou aux
embryons c'est pourquoi le mot poissons
pour les biologistes et les
paléontologues est rapidement devenu
synonyme de vertébrés puisqu'il désigne
exactement la même chose des animaux à
vertèbres et qui possède des branchies à
au moins un moment de leur développement
mais si vous ne possédez que des
branchies comme ça a été le cas pour
certaines espèces d'étranges
d'invertébrés à coki nommer les carpes
aux ide
alors vous n'êtes pas ou du moins pas
encore un poisson par contre vous en
êtes peut-être des très proches parents
et si comme la fiac sus vous ne posséder
qu'une corne dorsale qui est à la
colonne vertébrale ce que l'échafaudage
est à la cathédrale mais que vous ne
possédez pas vraiment de branchies
squelettiques
alors vous n'êtes pas non plus à
poissons par contre vous aurez peut-être
deux très proches parents abondent lui
aussi est very deux théories
s'affrontent ce sont les choses qui
arrivent
par contre si comme me le coût de médias
ou itunes disent athées souhaite vous
avez à la fois des branchies et une
cordée dorcel c'est-à-dire l'échafaudage
vertébrale et que vous avez plus de 500
millions d'années alors là vous pouvez
commencer à prétendre au titre de plus
ancien poids sont connus maintenant que
nous savons définir ce qu'est un poisson
tâchant de savoir ce qu'est un poisson
cartilagineux dans la grande famille des
poissons on distingue les poissons à ce
que les cartilages in les poissons à
squelette aux ceux qui comprennent les
poissons à nageoires réunionnais et les
poissons à nageoires charnue dont nous
faisons partie et les poissons cuirassé
à mâchoires totalement distinct qui
tousse really forment ensemble la
famille des poissons à mâchoires ce
groupe rassemble des poissons dont les
premières paires de branchies se sont
spécialisés dans la prise de nourriture
on les différencie ainsi des poissons
sans mâchoires qui ont une histoire un
peu particulière leurs branchies à eux
n'ont pas d'autre fonction que la
respiration et la filtration des
particules alimentaires de l'eau on y
distingue des formes cuirassé toutes
disparues et des formes non curat c'est
comme els ampe roi actuel
cette dernière loin d'être une
survivante des temps anciens est en fait
issu d'une très longue histoire
évolutive durant laquelle ses ancêtres
ont fait carrière dans le vampirisme les
vertébrés des restaurants ce que nous
appelons communément des poissons ceux
des étals des poissonneries seront
comptées parmi les poissons osseux
annales voir rayonner mais les requins
eux font partie des poissons
cartilagineux donc selon votre
définition du mot poissons les requins
peuvent tout aussi bien ne pas êtres des
poissons âgés dans les définitions à
géométrie variable
quelle relation ces poissons entretien
et il les a avec les autres
déjà les poissons sans mâchoires
présente les caractéristiques les plus
primitives et sont donc à coup sûr à
l'origine des poissons munis de mâchoire
sans oublier les poissons sans mâchoires
actuelle après c'est là que ça se
complique
parmi les poissons à mâchoires on a
longtemps cru que les poissons cuir
assez vite à l'origine des requins l'un
des caractères majeur soutenant cette
hypothèse était la présence d'une perte
d'appétit sexuel nommer les classes père
des sortes de pénis si vous voulez
partager par ces deux groupes
en effet les classes père sont l'apanage
des requins uniquement et leur
permettent de pratiquer la pénétration
et la fécondation interne ce qui n'est
pas très banal sous l'océan dans la
mesure où la semence ne risque pas de se
dessécher une fois dehors
la plupart des poissons pratique la
fécondation externe et la présence de
classe faire à la fois chez un requin et
les poissons duras et apparaissait donc
comme
innovation morphologiques physiologique
et comportementales importante partager
hérité d'un ancêtre commun un petit
problème est que les classes père ne
sont portés par définition que par les
individus mal ce qu'ils limitent
l'efficacité de ce caractère pour la
reconnaissance de fossiles mais le très
gros problème c'est que la présence de
classe père semble avoir été généralisée
à tous les poissons comme en a témoigné
la découverte et du très bien nommé
microbes ractis dit qui de plus certains
poissons cura c'est comme antennes natus
possède une mâchoire formé par des
portions de l'épiderme aussi fier et pas
cartilagineuse une caractéristique
garantie 100% en poissons osseux alors
là ça devient le gros bazar là dedans
sans parler du film de certains
spécialistes n'hésitent pas à enraciner
le groupe des poissons cartilagineux
directement parmi les poissons sans
mâchoires tello dont les écailles
thermique et brand caleçon
remarquablement similaire à celle des
poissons cartilagineux tout le problème
de l'origine des poissons cartilagineux
tient dans leur nom ils ont en effet
comme particularité d'avoir à ce que
l'aide fait de cartilage du genre qui ne
fossilise pas facilement et donc à la
question mais comment reconnaît-on un
fossile de poisson cartilagineux nous
substitueront celle ci qu'est ce qui
dans leur registre fossile peut être
reconnue comme ayant appartenu à des
poissons cartilagineux la nuance est
mince mais pas sans importance comme
vous allez pouvoir le constater les plus
anciens fossiles qui ont peut être
attribuée à coup sûr à des pressions
cartilagineux sont ceux de l'airbus
il ne s'agit pour l'instant que dedans
datant des liens 411 millions d'années
mais les plus anciens fossiles ayant pu
appartenir un poisson cartilagineux sans
qu'on en soit sûr pour autant date eu de
460 millions d'années il s'agit de
quelques écarts thermiques qui comme
chez les requins et les raies actuelle
sans constituer des mailles et deux en
chine comme des dents oui oui vous avez
bien entendu la peau des requins
recouverte de millions de microscopiques
dans ou en fait c'est plutôt la bouche
des requins qui est garnie de centaines
de grosses écailles qui ont évolué et se
sont transformées en dans méditel et
cahill ne sont pas l'apanage des seuls
poissons cartilagineux car comme nous
l'avons dit plus haut des poissons plus
anciens et sans mâchoires l'été l'eau
dont tu avais des écailles similaires
ces écailles d'attribution du
se retrouvent ensuite dans le registre
fossile pendant 50 millions d'années
avant que n'apparaissent les premiers
instants de poissons cartilagineux
indéniable de 50 millions d'années vous
vous rendez compte c'est comme si on
plaçait l'extinction des dinosaures
entre borne ouailles à 60 et 65 millions
d'années au bio fois voilà la louche les
10-15 millions d'années 1
voilà le gouffre entre les deux c'est
l'origine des poissons cartilagineux
imaginer le registre fossile des
primates avec le même gouffre ce serait
le retour direct à l'état de nos
connaissances en la matière au xviie
siècle
heureusement il existe quelques
spécimens remarquablement conservés qui
sont une mine d'informations pour les
paléontologues le plus ancien d'entre
eux et au bio du ski a vécu au dévonien
inférieur au canada il ya entre 400 et
410 millions d'années do you do atouts
du poisson cartilagineux la morphologie
dentaire très spécifiques
le renouvellement des dents en rangées
bien alignées de l'intérieur d'un
l'extérieur et à ce que l'être
entièrement cartilagineux
miraculeusement préservée 2010 a aussi
une autre petite particularité d epinal
allant des nageoires comme on en
rencontre était très peu chez les
poissons cartilagineux de tels the pin
sont peu communes
citons celle sur la tête des ibode honte
et à la vendée nageoire dorsale des xena
quand et de cloud oc la cus mais jamais
on ne les avait retrouvés à l'avant des
nageoires pectorales le saut chez un
groupe de poissons à mâchoires nommer
les a quand odien à brûler les atlantes
odien non non non les a quand odien
initiaux nomme parfois les requins
épineux basse et du poisson
cartilagineux ça alors
et justement c'est une question qui pose
un épineux problème aux paléontologues
car les akans te dire mon d'affinités
franche avec aucun des groupes de
poissons à mâchoires dont nous avons
parlé mais il ressemble quand même un
peu plus aux poissons cartilagineux qu
aux autres de par leur renouvellement
dentaire qui se fait par rangée
successives au moins chez certains
d'entre eux comme thomas quand tu si à
l'heure actuelle les attentes audiences
sont donc les plus sérieux candidats à
l'origine des poissons cartilagineux et
maintenant c'est parti pour l'histoire
des poissons cartilagineux
les extraordinaires voici l ico prions
et s'inspirera dedans c'était un quand
tu sais ça brasse et dorsale les îlots
de terribles rocade
nous parlons de poissons cartilagineux
qui hantait les maires quand les
dinosaures régnaient sur la terre nous
parce qu'alors là on me signale dans les
commentaires de la vidéo que ça devient
je cite gauche blanc de dire à chaque
fois poissons cartilagineux alors que
y'a pas à tortiller les trucs dedans
vous rabattez les oreilles depuis tout à
l'heure ça ressemble à du requin ça
appartient à la famille des requins
alors utiliser le mot requins et arrêtez
de nous les hacher menu mais c'est
exquis comme langage j'espère que les
choses soient bien claires les requins
je veux dire les vrais requins sont plus
proches des raies actuel qui ne le sont
deux hélicos prions d ibo dante ou de
n'importe quel autre poissons fossiles
dont on vous a parlé jusqu'à présent
cela signifie que les règles sont
génétiquement plus proche d'un requin
qui n'ont jamais pu l'être ces autres
espèces donc si vous appelez ça ça et ça
rk alors vous ne devez plus appeler
c'est très une ré mais arcade c'est
automatique
allez-y et vidic le que ça c'est un
requin non non c'est juste n'importe
quoi appelons les choses par leur nom
alors s'il vous plaît appelons un chat
un chat un requin un requin et une ré
d'une raie et ça va ça ça c'est juste
des poissons cartilagineux ce sont
d'autres poissons cartilagineux parce
que par exemple la possibilité qu hélico
prions soit une forme proche des
chimères un autre groupe de poissons
cartilagineux tu ne sont ni des rennie
des requins est encore à l'étude
bon bon bon ne nous énervons pas et
prenons un exemple plus parlant voici
deux sportifs on voit sur ces
photographies qu'ils pratiquent le même
sport le tennis et voici d'autres
sportifs je sais pas quel sport il
pratique deux sous prétexte que je ne
sais pas où classer ces sportifs et sous
prétexte que pour moi tous les sportifs
sur semble dire que ces sportifs sont
des tennismans et ça m'arrangerait bien
ça nous simplifier le langage et
ce serait complètement faux alors
pourquoi par les écailles devrions nous
dire que ces poissons cartilagineux sont
des requins il leur semble
comme n'importe quel poisson peut
ressembler un requin et même si c'est
très pratique de dire que ce sont des
requins et c'est tout simplement faux
les raies et les requins partagea
certain nombre de caractères hérité de
leurs ancêtres communs exclusif ses
caractéristiques uniques ne se retrouve
chez aucun d'autres poissons
cartilagineux il possède primitivement
anema dentaire constitué de trois
couches alors que les ibode honte et les
poissons cartilagineux n'en manque une
ou deux tout au plus ils ont aussi une
mâchoire diaboliquement mobile est situé
sous le crâne est pas à la vente de
celui-ci et les requins et les raies ont
des vertèbres aussi fier après tout à
fait atypique vous voyez pour des
poissons qu'on dit cartilagineux alors
s'il vous plaît les mots ont un sens et
celui du mont requin est très précis
megalodon était un requins le requin
blanc est un requin mais si pour vous
vivrez n'est pas un requin alors ceci ne
doit plus être appelé requin voilà je
crois que c'est bon on a bien l'enfant
sur le cloud à hasnon mais j'insiste on
pourrait croire que c'est une erreur
trivial mais elle a un impact important
en la faisant vous sous-entendez que les
requins sont apparus il ya 4 160
millions d'années alors qu'en réalité
ils sont plus vieux que la ligne ayant
donné naissance aux mammifères et vous
nous et c'est le mythe selon lequel il
serait les artefacts évolutif des grands
papys du darwinisme bref des fossiles
vivants
c'est stop c'est terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi pour tout savoir de
l'évolution des poissons cartilagineux
nous vous conseillons les excellents
ouvrages de jrc unis bon ok il commet
dans l'un de ces bouquins l'erreur qui
conduit à l'idée reçue qui est critique
dans l'autre il m'en reste pas moins que
c'est aux spécialistes de la question et
que ces livres sont très complets écrit
avec beaucoup de passion et
magistralement illustré à consommer sans
modération
merci à tous